So because I've been staying home, I've been
reading a lot.
So I have four recommendations for you today.
Of course, I hope you were staying home.
Reading is a great thing to be doing.
David Pakman dot com slash recommendation's.
You can find today's recommendations and all
of my others.
And if you use the links on that page to buy
the books, we get a little slice of your Amazon
transaction.
That's David Pakman dot com slash recommendations.
OK, this is one of the best narrative nonfiction
books I've read.
Hunting Eichmann by Neil Bascomb.
It's the story of a hunting finding and capturing
and ultimately trying and sentencing to death
of Nazi Adolf Eichmann.
He was caught in Argentina where I was born,
living under the name Ricardo clÉment in
1960.
The story is incredible.
This is what Neil Bascomb has done is incredible.
There are 75 pages of footnotes, all of the
interviews, transcripts that Neil Bascom combed
through to create a narrative story of the
capture of Adolf Eichmann.
I cannot recommend this more highly fantastic
nonfiction book.
You'll love it.
OK.
Number two, New Jack by Ted Canova.
This is a book that was recommended to me.
I don't remember by Who Knew Jack Guarding
Sing.
Sing is the story of journalist Ted Canova,
who wanted to do a story on being a corrections
officer, sometimes pejoratively referred to
as a prison guard and not getting access to
the training program and to.
Corrections officers.
So Ted Canova decided to take the admissions
test to become a corrections officer after
two years, was invited to go to the academy,
did it and actually worked at Sing Sing Prison
up upstate from a New York City.
It's again, an incredible narrative nonfiction
book.
It's almost 20 years old at this point.
Excellent, excellent book.
Couldn't recommend it more highly.
Now for something different.
I recently read the book by His Holiness the
Dalai Lama.
Beyond Religion, it's a very interesting take
on how Dalai Lama believes that you don't
actually need religion to create a sort of
functioning, moral and ethical framework.
A lot of religious figures believe religion
is the only way to a moral and ethical framework.
And this is beyond religion, ethics for a
whole world by the Dalai Lama.
Excellent.
Interesting.
A very quick read, only about 180 pages.
Read it in a few days.
And the writing is is compelling.
It's interesting.
And it gives a perspective on how the Dalai
Lama sees Buddhism fitting into non.
I guess we would call it a more secular ethics,
a more secular moral framework.
Very interesting.
And then lastly, I've been reading a lot of
sort of older narrative nonfiction, Liar's
Poker by Michael Lewis.
Liar's Poker was written in I believe it was
the late 80s or early 90s.
Let me see here.
It was written in.
I'm having trouble actually finding that page.
In any case, it's the story of Michael Lu
in 89, Michael Lewis working for the now defunct
Salomon Brothers in bond trading in the 1980s.
It gives you incredible insight, number one,
into the boys club.
That was Wall Street in the 1980s.
Number two.
Wall Street has definitely changed significantly
since this book was written.
And it's a very, very interesting inside look
and extraordinarily well written by Michael
Lewis.
That's Liar's Poker by Michael Lewis.
All of today's recommendations and my years
of recommendations divided into fiction and
nonfiction and other categories at David Pakman
dot com slash recommendations.
If you're looking for things to read as you
self isolate social distance, physically distance.
This is a great time to pick up some of my
recommendations.
David Pakman dot com slash recommendations.